that people like he looks so slow I saw
those comments he slows molasses
whatever here's the other thing we don't
know what round that is what's what part
of sparring that is we don't know if
he's been in there with six fresh bodies
and this guy jumps in we don't know if
this is the eighth sparring round we
don't have to do the 12th sparring round
we don't know either way I don't need uh
he looks pretty [__] good Jake and if
he's taking that guy's 30-1 so
um and he's walking for he's walking him
down which can be a problem for Jake
without pressure like I'm telling you
man if if Nate respects Jake like I
think he will if he respects him and
takes it serious Jake could be in some
trouble man
the problem is Jake Just Hits hardest
and he's quick early on but is that the
longer that fight goes the better for
Nate online people are hating on Nate
right like you look so slum like I
didn't see that here I see a a nape
putting in some work against the 31 guy
also Landing some great body work went
to the head and just walking him down
like Terminator